أنت تعلم أن الماء هو
العنصر الأساسي للحياة ، حيث يبلغ طول نافورة دبي التي
يزيد طولها عن 900 قدم مع إطلاق المياه
ما يقرب من 500 قدم في السماء ،
يدعي مطوروها أن هذه هي أطول نافورة أداء في العالم ،
لكن يجب أن
أقول هذا الارتباط هنا في دبي ،
أعتقد أننا صنعنا  من النوع الذي كان من
بنات أفكار السيد خصائص الذي
طور وسط مدينة دبي عندما
وضعنا هذه الخطة الرئيسية ، كنا
نفكر في القيام بشيء لم يتم
القيام به أبدًا إذا رأيت أين نحن حاليًا ،
يمكنك زيارة دبي مول الذي يعد
أكبر مركز تسوق هو خليفة
العالم.  أطول مبنى ثم
نافورة الوداع وهي أكبر
نافورة راقصة حيث يمزج الضوء والماء ،
لذا بالنسبة للمشاريع بهذا الحجم ، فإنهم يتطلعون
إلى تبليل الشركة التي تقف وراء بعض
أكثر النوافير شهرة في العالم عندما
تعهدنا بأنك تعلم أن هناك
بعض القلق  كنا نأخذ شيئًا
نعرف أنه يعمل جيدًا في
بيلاجيو وهو استخدام
الموسيقى الشعبية ودمجها واستخدامها
القوة الدافعة لهذه
الانفجارات الأدائية الرائعة للمياه ، لكن
هذه لم تكن لاس فيجاس للرجل
المسؤول عن توجيه هذه الرقص المائي الذي
صمم التسلسلات في دبي ، وهو ما
جلب تحدياته الخاصة عندما صممت
نافورة يعتمد نهجي على
مكان وجود النافورة  مثال في
الثقافة العربية ، المبدأ الرئيسي هو
أن الموسيقى متشائمة مقابل متفائلة ،
لذا فأنت في الواقع تحني ركبتك
عند الإيقاع ولا تقفز للأعلى كما هو الحال في
الثقافة الغربية أيضًا مع وظائف كبيرة
علينا التأكد من أن
الكوريغرافيا ممتعة من جميع الزوايا.
نافورة دبي كبيرة جدًا لديك
تجارب مختلفة اعتمادًا على
المكان الذي تكون فيه بعد القطع
المصممة على الكمبيوتر ،
يجب اختبارها في الموقع حيث
يتم إخفاء التكنولوجيا المصممة خصيصًا بعيدًا عن أعماق الأرض ،
ونحن نستخدم الكثير من التكنولوجيا الروبوتية التي
تتيح لنا إظهار  المرض بطريقة
تجعل الناس غير معتادين على
مقدار الضغط وكل
مرة تقارب 500 PS ثا  تقدم لنا
عرضًا مذهلاً ،
يمكن أن ترتفع أعلى النافورة إلى السماء بمسافة 150 مترًا
تقريبًا لمبنى مكون من 50 طابقًا ،
وقد صممت أكثر من 250 نافورة
وميزة مائية في أكثر من 20 دولة ولديها
حاليًا أكثر من 60 براءة اختراع
لتقنية جديدة هم  لقد ابتكرنا ما
نسعى جاهدين لفعله وهو رطب هو أخذ
العنصر الرائع للمياه وجعله
تجريبيًا وحقيقيًا ومختلفًا
للناس ، ونحن نتشارك مع الماء
لإنشاء أشياء من شأنها إبهار
الناس وترفيههم ، وقد أصبحت دبي على
مر السنين  المكان الأكثر خصوصية
للرطوبة نحب أن نبني أشياء مثيرة
وحديثة وسريعة ورطبة
ووجدنا مكانًا للقيام بذلك